and I want to read you something that
Nietzsche wrote it's perhaps the most
famous thing he ever said although it's
almost entirely taken out of context and
misquoted and if not misquoted at least
misunderstood because Nietzsche was one
of these strange people who was capable
of living 50 or even a hundred years
into the future and although he was is
generally regarded as an enemy of
Christianity and superstition and was
certainly an unbelievably outspoken
opponent of Christian traditionalism he
also knew that if you let the old gods
die the probability that blood would
flood the land was virtually 100 percent
so let me read you what he wrote have
you not heard of that madman who lit a
lantern in the bright morning hours ran
to the marketplace and cried incessantly
I seek God as many of those who do not
believe in God were standing around just
then he provoked must much laughter why
did he get lost said one did he lose his
way like a child said another or is he
hiding is he afraid of us has he gone on
a voyage or emigrated that's they yelled
and laughed
the madman jumped into their midst and
pierced them with his glances whither is
God he cried I shall tell you we have
killed him you and I all of us are as
murderers but how have we done this how
are we able to drink up the sea who gave
us the sponge to wipe away the entire
horizon what did we do when we Unchained
this earth from its Sun whither is it
moving now whither are we moving now
away from all suns are we not plunging
continuously backwards sideward forward
in all directions
is there any up or down left are we not
straying as though through an infinite
nothing do we not feel the breath of
empty space has it not become colder is
not night and more night coming on all
the while must not lanterns be lit in
the morning do we not hear anything yet
of the noise of the gravediggers who are
burying God do we not smell anything yet
of God's decomposition
God's to decompose god is dead
God remains dead and we have killed him
how shall we the murderer of all
murderers comfort ourselves what was
holiest and most powerful of all that
the world has yet owned has bled to
death under our knives who will wipe
this blood off us what water is there
for us to clean ourselves what festivals
of atonement what sacred game shall we
have to invent is not the greatness of
this deed too great for us must we not
ourselves become God simply to seem
worthy of it all as you can tell it's a
much different notion from the casual
god is dead quotation that's most
generally associated with Nietzsche well
what is he saying he's saying something
like this a system like Christianity or
any system that's that's oriented a
society for thousands and thousands of
years can't simply be eradicated by a
casual gesture without consequences
ensuing in its aftermath what
consequences well Nietzsche says well we
all no longer know up from down what
does he mean by that
metaphorically well up that's where
you're headed right and down that's what
you want to stay away from and when you
eradicate the most fundamental
presuppositions of your system of values
then there is no up and there is no down
and then where are you precisely well
it's not so easy it's not so easy to say
having not necessarily ever been in that
position what is your life like when you
don't know up from down is it merely
neutral is it is there merely no value
left or could it possibly be the case
that if up and down have both being
eradicated that the place that you're
left and is something much more akin to
a permanent state of suffering because
maybe it's only the case that the
constant capacity to strive through up
in being enough that you believe in the
constant striving for up is actually
what makes you
life durable to you and if you lost the
sense of up and down the place that you
would end up would be not so much
neutral as terrible now if you have any
belief system at all you do this so
let's say you're an advocate of
left-wing politics you take a
pro-environmental stance or an
anti-corporate stance this is a
relatively common thing to do among
undergraduates what do you do when you
hold that belief system they view the
world as it lays itself out and you
explain the manner in which it manifests
itself in terms of the axioms of that
belief system and you may know that you
can do it right you can tell a credible
story about why the world is the way it
is by adopting say an anti-corporate
perspective because there are all sorts
of terrible things about the world that
are a consequence say of corporate
maneuvering and you might also say that
and Piaget would say this that it's a
necessary developmental stage to acquire
allegiance to a given belief system why
well any up is better than none that
might be the first observation so even
if your belief system is relatively
insufficient and easily challenged on
intellectual grounds and perhaps not
very complete anyways
the fact that it does lay out a moral
structure for you and tell you good from
evil and right from wrong that's a
that's a plus that's an advantage now
it's relative intellectual weakness and
it's incoherence assuming it it is
incoherent to some degree that's a flaw
but that doesn't mean that the effort to
establish a system like that is
worthless it's worthwhile and Nietzsche
said say with regards to Christianity
and Europe he said well the errors
intellectual and moral of institutional
Christianity are essentially beyond
count but there's one thing you have to
remember first of all an ordering of
that sort is necessary because the
alternative which is always hidden from
you insofar as you're inside a moral
system the alternative is far worse
chaos that's worse